what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
top rewards here video requests a day
from man named Pete dawn this comes from
the channel puffin forests these guys
are killing it right now over one guy
I'm not sure D&D story dungeon master
dot exe has crashed
all right title alright let's do it tack
the school attack at the school
I don't know installer code text my new
dungeon dragons campaign started five
hundred years after the old one finished
up I started to introduce a lot of
advanced technology to my world with the
rise of airships flintlocks and match
tech devices the group all had to make
up new characters to start on this
adventure or so I thought seriously the
same character well so there's no reason
he can't make it you know well I was
wondering initially while you weren't
telling me anything about your new
character that you were making for this
campaign you're supposed to be different
I am different character development I'm
wearing a hat now does not count as
character development it doesn't you
guys can see me of course we can they
don't know what it's been like for
hundreds of years the shadow punk I can
pass without a trace and using
visibility normally they won't last for
a short time one day go away I became so
stealthy and sneaky that no one could
hear or see me I tried poking the
product yeah like shouting but no one
would notice me for the past 500 years
weird limbo state wandering the lands in
search of a way to fix it but to no
avail and
I'm cursed with being permanently
invisible invisable
we came back yeah
Michelle was invisible permanently now
apparently in the main storyline the
group was chasing down a band of
lycanthropes like werewolves where
there's where Tigers etc calling
themselves the wild things the players
had to figure out where their hideout
was waiting or taking down a group
calling themselves the wild things
general location the spot where they're
operating from I have no one to blame
but myself for this location called
the carnival where they would fight each
other as a test of strength to see what
animals would rise to the top of the
chain at night they would hunt preying
on other humanoids they were kind of
like a leper colony
a faction made up of downtrodden and
fearful people that had been cursed with
the Lycans bite before they had lived in
fear that someone would find out their
secret those cursed had gotten swept up
in the Ryder wreck which said that the
world was broken down into predators and
prey if you weren't a predator you're
nothing more than prey our group hunted
down the headquarters and led to a fight
to take the gang down what's that it's a
good blade yeah but it's a blade and a
gun so gun blade this is a very
self-explanatory game no bad where's it
from how did you ever played Final
Fantasy 8 during the fight they got a
new player to the party she hadn't
introduced herself yet her druid went
over to heal someone I don't know if I
trust her
I believe her character some random
stranger comes over to me in the middle
of a battle and wants to heal me she'd
be one of those monsters I don't think I
follow
and then she revealed what her character
looked like never mind
she's she's so cute I completely trust
her after they dealt with the Lycan cult
the players next minute had them trying
to get into this private boarding school
the Institute was closed to outsiders so
they had to figure out a way to get in
our paladin is like everyone just hang
around for a little bit I'm going to go
get a warrant so we can search the
school legally don't get into any
trouble
well I'm gone just hang out here as she
leaves the other players decide yeah
we're not gonna wait and they attempt to
break in to get into the school each one
had their own strategy one guy disguised
himself as a teacher and others the tour
guide others says disguise myself as a
student all right you're among them but
I didn't roll anything it's all right
you automatically succeed Michelle had
to get past several teachers so he uses
the massive foldable boat to knock them
unconscious and break through part of
the wall what are you doing us we cut
backs and pouted who's writing out the
details of the warrant on this stage I
hereby authorize the designate team to
carry out the following activities
pursuant to the law then we cut back to
the school at the lunch room where a
thief also decided to disguise himself
as a student and he starts standing the
other students out of the lunch money
playing these little gambling games all
right you guys double your money just
keep your eyes on the Queen which he
stole a bunch of their money to protect
our thief our Giroud lit one of them on
fire back to the Paladin who's quietly
filing paperwork but she has to go
through one of the officers and you know
they're taking their sweet time signing
in and let me cut back to the lunch room
where samurai says don't worry you guys
I can calm them down I've got an idea
he then whips out his pistol and fires
it into the ceiling
everyone calm down just do as I say and
no one has to get hurt which caused an
immediate mass hysteria several guards
rushed over to him with weapons drawn
put down the gun we cut back over to our
paladin who now has finished filing the
paperwork and is casually strolling over
to the school warrants in hand to be let
in
legally we cut back over to the rest of
the party where the assault on the
boarding school continues this is just a
regular school okay it's not like an
evil school it's just a regular school
which they're attacking our new monk is
already attacked several teachers
knocking about students are playing one
of the children is set on fire our theme
is stealing money from all the children
and teachers it's just absolute
pandemonium the police officers are
yelling at us drop the weapon you police
officer you put your guns down huh what
what do you guys think you get to tell
me what to do when you're not even
dropping your own weapons but also well
this is happening in real life the
player who is playing as the Baron asked
me hey Ben do you have a blank character
sheet I say yes sir sir and I give it to
him I'm deviously handling the child
hostage negotiation the penny tension
but the player starts writing on it as
he's doing that or paladin is
approaching school and see several
children fleeing and hears rumors that
there's an active shooter she draws her
weapon and Raoul's Lee the police in a
standoff with their friend and a child
is still on fire are these companions of
yours companions is a very loose time
thief
very very loose term the samurai is
getting worried press it back he starts
thinking about what to do actually is a
sudden of hip knee don't worry I know
just the thing that will defuse this
situation oh great
what did you have in mind and he
produces from underneath his clothes a
makeshift explosive drop your weapons he
says or else I'll set this off he rules
intimidation fails one of the guards
tries to shoot the grenade Oh is he in
misses which causes the samurai go you
asked for it he pulls the pin and tosses
it into the crowded room our paladin
leaps forward on top of the grenade
taking the blast but severely damaging
her you really don't get who you're
dealing with here as he lifts his cloak
aside to reveal many other sets of
explosives around him
sway to God I'm taking all of you with
me before you can do that he has tackled
by that restraint and sent off to prison
Oh Charles
okay well the samurai was imprisoned the
Paladin ended up being the hero see
there you go
they trust you now because of me very
also during this time the player who had
Beryl swapped out his character for a
new one okay what was the thing I know
it didn't explain earlier but that
samurai the one who shot up the school
was a part of the Barons household
famous black rose both of the characters
were wearing the House insignia the
samurai actually works under the Baron
and now that his samurai has been
dishonored the Baron is like I need to
slit and he books it completely out of
the story okay so in the meantime that
player made up a new character to fill
his old ones place
are you a shredder that you ever see
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles the paladin
was not excited to get the samurai back
into the party the two had already been
on tense relations before since the
samurai had already tried to kill the
paladin once and also murdered another
civilian oh not only
but not a few hours later the samurai
broke out of prison and now he's on the
run with a bounty on his head
it's one thing to have a player riff for
him where it's like oh yeah these two
characters you know they don't really
see eye to eye but yeah they kind of
work together the same party no no
because I knew that if he showed up back
in the party the group would probably
just sent in practicin and collect the
reward money wait a second I think I
know how they could make this work for
them that is a smart idea very nice as
sad as
a good money-making technique Johnny
played Dungeons & Dragons yeah oh so
much of the time I do that activity have
you ever never played it no I know a
little bit about it I'm always
fascinated by how kind of complex and
intricate it looks from the outside I
had about as much understanding do you
watching this video as I do in real life
yeah I've never played Dungeons and
Dragons I watched that phantom
entertainment documentary about Dungeons
& Dragons so I have more understanding
than I did before did you all our land
Wayans film no I have not
so wait you're the one that was the best
thing ever I like this video because
this is easily the most digestible I've
ever had
of Keeping Up with Dungeons & Dragons
I've been in the room when people are
playing and I'm like I don't know what
you guys are doing yeah very much lost
if there's a way for me to kind of
understand it at all this is the way to
do it
was I lost a little bit at times sure
Pete Don would it help to have a little
bit of context as to what we were
walking into all right I mean two
minutes into it going okay I think I
know what's going on I feel like I would
have probably whatever helped out a
little bit so here you go watch this
yeah yeah I was sort of like oh should I
have watched a bunch of other things
first or just play a lifetime's worth of
the middle of it yeah yeah in the
beginning I was a little bit confused
but I think this guy's animation is
wonderfully done I do like his sense of
humor that he brings to the table here
because like I said it does make it
easier to latch on to what this
storyline element is and we really this
kind of did make me go I wouldn't mind
playing the game now like if I could
pick up on what's going on through this
I might be able to get the gist of it
what I'm doing it when I had a slightly
exasperated charm of you know a dungeon
master Rick counting like okay I had to
deal with kind of everybody's
personalities and here's what this guy
decided to do and it seems like Dungeons
& Dragons again from my limited
perspective would allow for a lot of
those kinds of variables during a game I
don't know exactly how it works but it
seems like you know heavily story based
it seems like there's a lot of potential
for just different avenues to run down
and so yeah especially for a web series
- I have to imagine
just a particularly amusing campaign was
always gonna lend itself to this Gannett
thing and no it didn't make me ya
curious to play
I like your Adult Swim animation yeah
you have here at the same time though
the sense of humor is child-friendly I
don't know about child-friendly but it's
you know it's it's not like
three-year-olds an adult
based you know vulgar humor which when
they first saw the animation I thought
it's the kind of territory we were
walking into but apparently not this is
something that I feel like families can
easily latch on to and I would really
appreciate it a lot of your editing
tricks as well this managed to be very
engaging and I think it's cool to have
something that can be appealing for
people who are non players because if
there's anything I've noticed in the
past year more and more people are in my
life I find out are into WWE and
dungeons track to conversations I often
feel out of the loop so yeah I feel like
I can watch more of your videos now and
feel like I can kind of keep up with the
conversation should you pick a roleplay
with a sense of humor like this when
we're playing the game haha I've had a
much better time at a D&D campaign by us
would be very very silly yeah I don't
know how much we would actually get done
or anything or how much you know we
would pill in but it would be it would
be fun anyway guys you can subscribe to
puffins Forest as soon as you can six
hundred thirty eight thousand followers
he deserves way more he's killing it
right now with what he's got going on
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell thanks Pete
dawn for sending this over Pete I know
you yourself are writing a bunch of
stories and you're catching up on some
movie franchises right now I encourage
you to keep being original to keep doing
your thing and to also release your
early drafts online to the public so you
can be judged harshly for early stages
of development and then see how well
your skin responds to such criticism and
if you are able to power your way
through that well you could be the next
Ed Wood oh dude that's a mantle right
there he's made one of the most notable
films of all time
and that could be you Pete get on it
take some of your DMD campaigns and
write a script and get on it